but that's another story dude now we
gotta do the Pod show brother yeah dude
that was a different time brother yeah
that's a very calm chaos perogan dude
yeah dude now we gotta do this
weekend was Black Adam starring The Rock
neither of you went to see it you must
now engaged in an astonishing
conversation as you attempt to answer
the question what is Black Adam this is
what is Black Adam begin
well it's a move what yeah I mean what
is Black Adam I know very little about
it uh I'll be honest it's advertised
everywhere
I know it's the rock I know it's a DC
character so in the the pantheon of like
comic book movies and universes there's
Marvel there's DC those are the two
biggest obviously DC is like uh I think
box office wise not quite as good as
Marvel because I don't think they have
as many movies they've got like the the
Batman [ __ ] the Justice League [ __ ] and
I know those are like Batman's and
Supermans and wonder womans are in there
I don't watch any of these [ __ ] Jason
Momo was Aquaman he's in there yeah dude
he's water man brother yeah dude he can
go into the water permission to come
aboard have you ever seen that movie I
ain't seen no Aquaman no I don't watch
Aquaman you gotta see it I don't want
I've seen there are some um there are
some Marvel movies that I [ __ ] love I
love Deadpool one and two can't wait for
the new one yep I've seen Guardians of
the Galaxy and uh one time I went crazy
crap brother hold on dude he's Mario
dude he's in space brother with a
talking raccoon and a [ __ ] giant twig
not anymore
hahaha
um
I'm I'm Super Mario Kart
um
yeah I've seen the Galaxy oh I also saw
the uh Avengers which one
the one where they're all anyway the one
the one where they're all in it and I
went to see it with uh I was I was
shooting a film
um in Atlanta and we all went to see it
on the weekend and the makers of this
film the director certainly and he we
had the effects guy and his DP and
everything they're all into that [ __ ]
and we were making an action movie boss
level jokes
hold on dude that movie was great
um
and we went and saw it it was good to
see it with filmmakers like that because
they had all sorts of opinions but I was
going in blind I don't know much about
these movies at all uh actually
superheroes did you read Comics grown up
oh
sometimes when I do that De Niro I get
no I didn't I read a lot of asterisks
and oblics uh Comics which are from uh
Norway or Sweden or something dude real
Art House [ __ ] well and
um I no I never read comic books really
I know you were a big comic book I read
them uh incessantly as a kid both Marvel
and DC and Darkhorse and all that kind
of [ __ ] I love the crow brother but
anyway Black Adam is a character that is
not to my knowledge I don't know much
about Black Adam
um I don't think that it's it certainly
isn't one of the main like Justice
League guys but I think he's a villain
yeah he's a bad guy uh not to get now
I'm talking a little too inside baseball
I just mentioned a [ __ ] movie and now
I'm going to mention that uh uh mapal uh
Zach from hey you ever watch uh what's
imperfect dude that was a sitcom a long
time ago and uh the Flash
right
what was that movie what was that no
what was the movie uh see he's Shazam
Shazam that's what I said oh and Black
Adam is from the Shazam Universe The
Flash is a different thing brother
because that's got an actor who's now
facing all kinds of weird criminal
charges dude yeah dude my pal was the
flash dude I don't think that's right
yeah I think he was Shazam brother but
Black Adam is a different deal I think
he's kind of hold on a second dude
Superman in in terms of like the powers
that he wields I think he's like a
Superman I thought he was the bad guy
for the uh for Shazam
oh see I don't know see I don't know
what plaque is a question I don't know
what the [ __ ] Shazam is I won't even go
and see him was I'm not asking you
that's a hypothetical he was a genie
that that gave powers to your buddy uh
no you're thinking of uh Kazam uh
starring Shaquille O'Neal yeah dude have
you seen those Billboards around La for
shocktoberfest nope it's an oktober
Festival like a Halloween thing but
promoted by Shaq and the Billboards are
like these weird cartoons of him with
skeleton hands and it says that it's
gonna be at the Queen Mary so that I'm
like I kind of want to go to it what the
[ __ ] is shacktoberfest that's a better
question dudesy uh forget what this
Black Adam what the [ __ ] is
shacktoberfest Black Adam is a movie now
knowing nothing about knowing not even
the titles of some of these movies even
though cohorts and Pals have been in
them I guess right
um I don't know what Black Adam is but I
would like to answer that question by
saying he's it's I'm watching The Rock
promote it on his Instagram and he says
we're in Taipei I got Big Bertha here my
my treadmill sure and we're having a
good time
we're promoting Black Adam and we're
promoting
[Laughter]
oh
Black Adam is a movie about a guy who's
got really good superpowers
yeah but I think he had there's some
traumas in his past life or some [ __ ] a
son I don't know exactly but this is the
biggest opening weekend of a rock movie
ever it says most successful really
financially yes well good for him and I
think it is they mean it to launch like
a series obviously with him I think his
next biggest one was the Sean Hobbes
spin-off but it did better than that so
yeah I have mild interest in seeing it I
guess I don't know to me it's you know
uh a good movie like that again I see so
few of these movies obviously
one thing I do like from these movies is
the human element you know and this is
why even super hero movies that you like
Chad could never be created by AI as you
uh tend to purport that they may be
someday no they can't because of the
heart in a movie like Black Adam there's
a lot of heart so I would say have you
seen the movie no how do you know this I
don't know this but I'm weird the
question is what is Black Adam yeah to
me okay I think the Black Adam has to
have they all have to have an origin
story yeah and I know that some bad
things happen to his family in this oh I
think I saw that in a trailer okay and I
think Black Adam is about uh he's
dealing I think the Black Adam is like
he's dealing with uh uh some depression
and he's yeah that's Black Adam he's
um
yeah it's no it's yeah he's it's just
it's like a moody it's almost like the
crow he's got like a movie like The Crow
dude I saw on a trailers flying around
he punches a [ __ ] airplane out of the
sky that ain't the crow
what is Black Adam
it is a movie
oh it stars Dwayne Johnson
and W he was the rocking WWE that's the
song black dude by Pearl Jam that's the
song I think so he's but he's punching
[ __ ] real hard and doing all that stuff
dude because of all the bad things that
happened in his life possibly would you
see this movie because I know you're a
purist with Hulk Hogan you won't watch
his movies this is a good point would
you watch a rock movie have you seen a
rock movie you've seen fast yeah I've
seen Fast and the Furious I've seen uh
uh uh San Andreas okay I've seen I've
seen I've seen a small handful of his
movies yeah but I as you say I am a
purist uh
I don't necessarily want to see going
back 20 years you know the rock became a
movie star and started to Branch out
from his work as a wrestler obviously
oh man my voice coughed right in Chad's
Direction and covet brought it from New
York for you thanks um
uh I was just in New York you know what
you know what that is that's New York
right okay hold on dude I'm talking
about Black Adam when I when these
movies started with the rock I'm like
I'm all good I like rock as a
professional wrestler
so yeah it's just like the Hogan thing I
don't necessarily run out to to see
these movies would I see Black Adam I
don't know you know yeah I don't know
it's no it's not on my it's not on my
list to be honest same I I will watch it
when it comes to streaming you got a big
loud TV here you know and where does
that one stream that would be Warner
Brothers I think made it right so it's
going to be an HBO Max
um yeah I gotta say with all the comic
book movies dude I went through I don't
know when this was a couple of weeks ago
and I was just looking at all the new
Marvel movies that are slated to [ __ ]
come out there's like a hundred of them
and all the movie posters look the same
and [ __ ] when I was a little kid you
would have told me that all these Marvel
movies all these DC movies are gonna
exist that would have blown my mind now
I'm just like burn out on it
it's a movie about a guy that uh has
some shitty stuff happen to him early I
you know he had some bad stuff happen to
his family but probably some [ __ ]
happened after that because once
excuse me oh man there's all sorts of
stuff going on with my voice today
um once bad stuff starts happening with
your family you might turn to the bottom
the bottle rather and hit the bottom of
that bottle yep and so he might be he
Black Adam is he gets very very uh sad
you think that's it he's just sad in the
movie and then he turns to the bottle
and he drinks some
dramana
and that's what gives him super powers
do you think he worked a tremana product
placement into the movie is there a
scene where he like trashes a [ __ ]
bar and there's like tramana featured
prominently in it and he drinks it but
unlike troumana in real life life which
makes you happy like dudesy hard hard
seltzer uh in this movie it makes him
angry and sad like alcohol tends to do
right and uh then he goes running around
uh punching the [ __ ] out of well this is
kind of like uh the Will Smith movie I
now forget the name of it where he was a
[ __ ] Superman superhero who was
depressed and kind of an alcoholic and
he goes to jail do you remember this uh
concussion that was it
uh no I don't remember that because I
don't know any of these [ __ ] movies
but in Black Adam him and Charlie's
Throne were super people I think it's
about my pitch is that it is about a guy
who has some bad stuff happening to his
family then he gets drunk then he beats
the [ __ ] out of people in a bar they all
happen to be superheroes he starts a
[ __ ] thing with them and then they
start coming around his home and they
start trying to [ __ ] with him while he's
just he's just inside I got the case of
the Wednesday fuckets that's what I'm
having a stack of blondies and uh two
pepperoni pizzas just Detroit style
is the Wednesday [ __ ] and then they
they show up at his house and then it's
like you know any sort of Liam Neeson
[ __ ] thing right a lot another movie
those movies have some Humanity in them
and uh and uh it's just him trying to
defend his home and he's real dark and
he does [ __ ] up [ __ ] like you know
punching airplanes out of the sky to
defend his home yeah I think that's what
it's about okay and I'm 100 sure that's
not not what it's about I don't know
what it is about that Black Adam is I
don't either well this was a waste of
time
thank you moving on thank [ __ ] I don't
know what the [ __ ] that's curious about
it to some degree I have like 10
curiosity about it what would you say
your percentages of curiosity 10 10 100
curiosity is like I'm definitely gonna
see that movie anything over 75
curiosity I'll see I don't give a [ __ ]
please
[Music]
do do
please tell the friend then